imagine the world that you want to live
in and that just cause will influence
your friends it'll influence who you
vote for it'll influence the way you
build your business and it'll influence
the culture of your company if you ask
me my just cause I imagine a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired feel
safe wherever they are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do
that's the world that I want to live in
and so I've committed all of my energy
in my career to help build that world I
personally have taken a bet on leaders
that I've made it my choice to find
support and celebrate the leaders that I
think are more likely to build that
world because I know that I can't build
it alone it's going to take massive
amounts of companies and Leadership to
create that world with me but I'm
agnostic as to the route that I take but
that's the world I want to live in so
that's what I've committed to knowing
full well that I'll never get there in
my lifetime